WE APPRECIATE YOUR INSIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Lisa: THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NEW QUESTIONS OVER
WHETHER FLORIDA COUNTIES ARE
CORRECTLY TABULATING CORONAVIRUS
DEATHS.
FOX 35 ORLANDO REPORTER HAS
THE STORY.
DANIELLE.
>> HEY, LISA.
THIS IS COMING UP BECAUSE WE
WERE SPEAKING WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER
YESTERDAY ABOUT SOME OF THE
NUMBERS REGARDING CORONAVIRUS
DEATHS.
WE HAD NOTICED THAT TWO PEOPLE
IN THEIR 20s HAD DIED FROM
COVID AND SO WE ASKED HIM IF
THERE WERE ANY UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS INVOLVED, AND ONE OF
THE ANSWERS REALLY SURPRISED US.
HE TOLD US THAT ONE PERSON
ACTUALLY DIED IN A MOTORCYCLE
ACCIDENT.
HE TOLD US THAT THAT HAD GONE
INTO THE COVID NUMBERS AND HE
AND ASKED THE STATE TO REMOVE
THAT NUMBER AND WHEN ASKED IF IT
HAD ACTUALLY BEEN REMOVED OR
CLEARED FROM THAT DATA, HE SAID
HE DIDN’T THINK SO.
HE WASN’T SURE.
HE WAS GOING TO DOUBLE-CHECK.
SO THAT’S WHEN WE STARTED ASKING
QUESTIONS.
>> Lisa:
>> Lisa: AND WHAT EXACTLY WE
-- CAN YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON WHAT YOU FOUND AND
WHAT QUESTIONS YOU ASKED?
>> RIGHT, SO WE WERE TOLD THAT
IT WAS A MAN IN HIS 20s WHO
DID TEST POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS BUT HAD DIED BECAUSE
HE WAS IN A MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT.
SO TODAY WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
FOLLOW-UP ON THIS TO FIGURE OUT
IF THIS IS STILL CURRENTLY IN
THE STATE DATA.
THE ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS, HIS OFFICE IS TELLING
US THAT THEY ARE WORKING TO TRY
TO CONFIRM IT TO SEE IF THAT
DEATH WAS CLEARED FROM THE
SYSTEM.
WE ALSO REACHED OUT TO THE
MEDICAL EXAMINER HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY BECAUSE THOSE
FOLKS HAVE TO CERTIFY THE COVID
DEATHS.
HE TOLD US THAT THAT DEATH WOULD
NOT BE QUALIFIED AS A
CORONAVIRUS DEATH.
"HE SAID IT’S ONLY IF COVID IS
THE CAUSE OF DEATH OR
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CAUSE OF
DEATH" WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO
THE STATEMENT OF HOW OFTEN THEY
TELL US THEIR HEALTH DEPARTMENT,
A COVID-19 DEATH IS
DETERMINATIVE COVID-19 IS LISTED
AS THE IMMEDIATE OR UNDERLYING
CAUSE OF DEATH OR LISTED AS ONE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT CONDITIONS
CONTINUED INTO THE DEATH.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW A
MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT MAY HAVE
ENDED UP IN THAT STATE DATA.
A LOT IS RIDING ON THESE
NUMBERS.
PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE ARE ACCURATE.
THERE ARE BIG DECISIONS, SCHOOL,
NORMAN’S MAKING DECISIONS
LOOKING AT THE DATA.
THAT’S WHY WE ARE ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS WHEN WE HEAR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
>> Lisa: WE ARE MAKING PUBLIC
HEALTH DECISIONS.
WE ARE MAKING DECISIONS THAT